I became fascinated by the distinction between success and mastery.
And when I heard about a set of archers up at Columbia,...
I decided to go visit them...
...because I wanted to understand what's called "target panic,"...
...what happens when you get almost too good.
And I stayed for three hours at this practice not expecting to...
...because I was witnessing this distinction between success and mastery.
I would see these archers, go up to shoot at a target that's 150 yards away,...
...unable to really do anything but reframe their sense of success in every moment,...
...seeing themselves as an archer who just hit a 9 but knows they can really hit a 10,...
...who just hit a 7 knows they can really hit a 9 and so on.
And it's a taxing pursuit but it occurred to me as I was watching them...
...that success is the ability to hit that 10 ring once...
...but mastery is the ability to know that it means nothing if you can't do it again and again.